[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi 5 mars de
nouvelles conditions d'utilisation pour
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble elles
seront testés à partir du mois d'avril
l'ambition réduire les nuisances sonores
les week-ends et jours fériés sur ce
plateau nous recevons des associations
de rivera et d'utilisateurs qui ont
travaillé sur le dossier
les yvelines doté d'un nouveau
multiplexe il va ouvrir donnant au
centre commercial vélizy 2 un complexe
de 18 salles 3800 fauteuil sur plus de
quinze mille mètres carrés nous avons pu
visiter le site en avant première ce
matin
et puis une idée de sortie en ces
vacances d'hiver le cirque nicolas asa
vata douchez est installé à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines des
représentations jusqu'à dimanche avec
pour thème cette année un voyage en
orient il était le patron du groupe
renault implantée dans les yvelines
notamment a dû en cours mais aussi de
l'alliance avec nissan carlos ghosn
pourra être libéré sous caution la
justice japonaise a accepté sa troisième
demande de libération l'ex pdg est
incarcéré au japon depuis trois mois
pour fraude fiscale et abus de confiance
une caution fixée à 8 millions d'euros
carlos ghosn aura pour obligation de
résider dans le pays l'appel contre
cette libération fait par le parquet de
tokyo a été rejetée un nouveau
multiplexe pour les yvelines il ouvrira
ses portes demain mercredi au centre
commercial vélizy 2 michael et demi
d'euros a pu visiter les lieux avant son
ouverture demain j - avant l'ouverture
du nouveau cinéma du centre commercial
vélizy 2 les derniers travaux se
terminent pour accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions le public
au total multiplex comprend 18 salles
pour en recevoir 3800 spectateurs alors
les salles sont pour moi tout de la même
qualité ça c'est les références
aujourd'hui tant qu'elles soient petites
ou grandes c'est les mamans on va de 95
places à 475 avec des écrans de 10 à 18
m elles sont toutes équipées de la
dernière tlg technologie d'imagés sont
pour un confort et une projection de
qualité maximum pour nos spectateurs au
niveau de la programmation le cinéma
proposera une large sélection sur
ces écrans pour attirer plus de six cent
mille spectateurs tous les ans on va
évidemment du blockbuster prêt familial
ça va être demain captain marvel mais
également qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon
dieu des choses comme ça au film
d'auteur 18 salles c'est vraiment la
diversité qu'on offre donc voilà du film
très populaire au film très d'auteur en
passant par des ugc culte donc la
reprise de films qui ont marqué
l'histoire du cinéma est également des
documentaires des films pour enfants des
bisses méritage des choses comme ça le
cinéma de 15 mille cinq cents mètres
carrés veut également assuré le
spectacle en dehors de ces salles
obscures pour cela le sida décidé de
laisser entrer l'art contemporain dans
ses murs les spectateurs pourront
notamment voir ses yeux de chat géant de
l'artiste claude lévêque travail sur le
thème du regard
certes le cinéma sont des regards sont
des yeux il a pensé à simone signoret
dans le film le chat et du coup fait il
ya eu ce travail en être le cinéma
ouvrira officiellement ses portes ce
mercredi 6 mars les premières séances
sont programmées à partir de 10 heures
cette phase de consultation soit doit
s'achever dans dix jours le grand débat
national se poursuit jusqu'au 15 mars
d'après les dernières données de la
préfecture des yvelines
190 réunions locales sont programmés ou
se sont déjà tenues sur le territoire
ouverte aux habitants elles permettent
d'aborder plusieurs sujets parfois en
groupe de travail à un grand débat qui
se formalise également avec des stands
de proximité ouverts dans des points de
passage comme dégâts écoutez ce premier
bilan dressé par le référent
départemental du grand débat au micro de
michael et demi d'euros on a beaucoup de
réunions par rapport à d'autres
départements au niveau national c'est la
quatrième le quatrième département
nombre de réunions donc ça montre un
vrai engouement un vrai intérêt et dans
les réunions les gens sont présents des
salles sont plutôt bons d avec dédé du
des réunions qui durent plusieurs heures
donc ça fonctionne les gens s'expriment
dans un an dans le calme sereinement et
une synthèse des propositions seront
remontés ensuite au seront traitées
pardon après le et 15 mars un nouveau
fonctionnement tout du moins temporaire
pour l'aérodrome de toussus le noble de
nouvelles
éditions d'utilisation du site vont être
testés à partir du 1er avril et ce
jusqu'au 30 septembre l'objectif affiché
réduire les nuisances sonores les
week-ends et les jours fériés alors
qu'une concertation publique sur le
sujet vient de s'achever autour de la
table pour en parler trois invités à ma
droite christian mauduit bonsoir et jean
valy bonsoir soir vous êtes les
présidents respectivement de
l'association ciel calme magny les
hameaux est la ccm h et de l'association
de défense de la vallée de la mérantaise
et de l'environnement de château fort et
l'environnement du château fort ça c'est
là des vmc voilà pour le sigle vous
faites partie d'une alliance associative
sur le sujet à ma gauche yves gasc
conçoivent un soir vous êtes le
président de l'union des aéro club de
toussus le noble alors ce test grandeur
nature va être menée qui va être mené le
fruit du travail que vous avez mené
pendant deux ans un peu plus de deux ans
même des négociations qui ont abouti sur
un accord entre vos associations de
riverains et d'usagers de cet aérodrome
pourquoi il était nécessaire d'agir et
de travailler ensemble
christian modules en fait il ya eu
beaucoup de modifications 2009 on a
changé des trajectoires c'est vrai qu'on
a supprimé vente arrière pour essayer de
réduire les nuisances sur une certaine
partie du territoire
malheureusement une concentration sur
une autre partie du territoire sur la
vente arrière actuelle et puis ensuite
il ya eu en 2011 de la nouvelle arrêtez
donc qui instaurait une plage de silence
et des plages de moindre bruit plages de
silence entre 12h et 15h les olympiades
et jours fériés uniquement entre le 1er
avril et le 30 si lacan et les week-ends
et jours fériés ensuite donc on s'est
aperçu que finalement il y avait quand
même encore beaucoup d'avions qui
volaient
et qui font encore beaucoup de bruit
donc et on a profité du fait que la dg
assez mis au point un système de mesure
de performances des avions en fonction
de leurs nuisances sonores ou en tout
cas de leur performance sonore s'ils
sont peu peu bruyant et donc on a
profité de ça pour essayer de mettre
gérer des permissions ou des
autorisations aux avions qui étaient
moins bruyant et au contraire pénaliser
ceux qui étaient très bruyant parce que
c'est cela qu'on entend le plus
évidemment un travail de longue haleine
également du côté de votre association
jean valy oui enfin on a participé au
même titre que plein de d'associations
des environs c'était là boration je
voudrais dire que depuis cette année
c'est la première fois finalement enfin
de piles de l'arrêté de 2011 qui a
instauré la plage silence et la première
fois que les utilisateurs les usagers
les aéro club et nous autres
associations avant réellement plus
discutés ont semblé mettre au point un
accord qui se décline en lui
article qu'on va avoir le temps de
présenter je voulais juste donner la
parole d'abord à yvias qu elle pourquoi
aussi c'était nécessaire côté usagers de
trouver un terrain d'entente finale or
donc moi je représente lui à t une
association de pilotes et notre objectif
est de voler de voler plus et de voler
de façon responsable et donc que ce que
nous souhaitions c'était avoir la
possibilité de récupérer un droit de
voler sous conditions pendant ses plages
de silence et en l'occurrence de
permettre aux avions les moins bruyants
de voler pendant ses plages de silence
c'est ce qui nous a permis de faire
cette avancée à la base c'est la mise en
place d'un outil de mesure du niveau
sonore des avions qui s'appelle calypso
qui était mis en place par la dg assez
et qui classe les avions en quatre
catégories à la catégorie à qui
représente les avions les moins bruyants
la catégorie b ceux qui sont un petit
peu plus bruyant ça va jusqu'à des
sachant qu'une conversation moyenne
comme celle que nous avons aujourd'hui
génère un bruit qui correspond à peu
près au niveau de la catégorie c est
effectivement des préoccupations des
deux côtés juste avant de présenter les
termes de cet accord
qui a nécessité quand même on le
rappelle plus de deux ans de
négociations est ce qu'on est satisfait
des deux côtés je vous donne d'abord la
parole avoue yves gasc ul côté usagers
on a beaucoup travaillé au début on se
connaissait pas trop on se comprenait
pas forcément et petit à petit au fil
des réunions de travail on a appris à se
connaître et à se comprendre et je pense
qu'on a trouvé un accord qui est
équilibrée sur certains côtés les
usagers auraient voulu obtenir un peu
plus je suis certain que côté riverains
également mais il est important de
trouver un accord de façon à avancer et
à sortir de la situation aux précédentes
celle de l'arrêté qui est de 2011
et d'avancer de mettre en place quelque
chose qui permette à chacun de gagner
aussi bien sûr des riverains
juste-milieu côté français c'est un peu
le même état d'esprit tout à fait en
fait on s'était aperçu qu'il y avait
effectivement cette tâche de silence que
tous les riverains vraiment accepte de
bon gré mais ce que ce que je veux dire
volontiers ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'en dehors de cette plage de silence
c'est à dire avant et après il y avait
tout un tas d'avion qui volaient qui
ferait beaucoup de bruit aujourd'hui on
est arrivés à un accord et on s'est mis
d'accord sur des plages horaires par
rapport aux catégories donc abcd voire
non classé du coup jean vallier si vous
pouvez nous présenter les termes de cet
accord ce que vous vouliez parler de ça
tout à l'heure qu'est ce qui est prévu
du coût à partir du 1er avril que que
prévoit cette expérimentation
pendant cette expérimentation qui
correspond à l'article 2 de l'accord qui
est encore porté huit comme je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure qui a été signé le 21
mars 2018 hanks a déjà un petit peu donc
l'article
2 prévoit donc l'autorisation pour les
avions classés a donc les moins bruyants
orient de voler pendant la plage de
silence alors que les avions les plus
bruyants ont des plages large d'un tel
excédent de vol pendant tout le week
sacile contrepartie finalement c'est
autorisé ces avions moins brillant mais
en contrepartie limiter les plages
horaires pour pour les avions plus
brillants paul domb donc sur le court
terme en fait les riverains vont y
gagner beaucoup parce qu'il va y avoir
beaucoup moins de vols d'avions bruyant
ceux qui sont classés c est dépendant
des plages horaires très importante de
week-end les pilotes vont est gagné par
le fait qu' ils vont pouvoir récupérer
la possibilité de voler avec ceux de
leur avion qui sont les moins brillants
les a et les b pendant ces fameuses
plages de silence
et comme c'est des avions très peu
bruyant ça devrait impacter très peu les
riverains et j'ajoute que sur le moyen
et long terme cet accord un effet très
vertueux c'est qu'ils encouragent les
pilotes à choisir des avions à voler sur
des avions les moins bruyants possible
et ça ça correspond à l'enclenchement
d'un mécanisme vertueux une spirale
vertueuse dans lesquels aussi bien les
riverains vont trouver leur avantage que
les pilotes
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
expérimentation alors on rappelle juste
que les concertations publiques s'est
achevé hier qui donne un cadre
finalement à cette expérimentation avec
la prise d'un arrêté qui interviendra
dans les prochains mois qu'est ce que
vous attendez de l'expérimentation qui
s'achèvera le 30 septembre
déjà on a mis au point un système de
mesures donc il va nous permettre de
valider que effectivement les
dispositions qui ont été présentés en
fin négociée est prise en compte dans
l'arrêté amène bien effectivement une
réduction globale du niveau de sonore
donc ce qu'on attend bas c'est
effectivement à la fin donc de ce 30
septembre la fin mais il faut quand même
un certain temps pour analyser les
résultats
ce qu'on attend c'est de vérifier
valider que effectivement on est arrivés
réduire le niveau sonore
voilà même attendre du côté exactement
les mêmes attentes clash ans que ce
qu'on espère c'est que le bilan sera
positif et significativement positif si
besoin nous sommes prêts à retravailler
ensemble pour ajuster à la marge est
toujours en respectant un équilibre
locaux de l'ot bâle cet accord de façon
à ce qu'il soit le meilleur possible
et je précise juste parce qu'on arrive à
la fin de cet entretien qui à la fin de
cette expérimentation une évaluation
sera faite par toutes les parties dont
côté utilisateur côté riverains pour
décider du maintien de modifications
d'éventuelles modifications ou tout
simplement de l'abandon de ces nouvelles
conditions on aura l'occasion d'ailleurs
de refaire un petit bilan en plateau
merci à vous trois inhabituelle pour
l'union des aéro clubs de tout sujet en
value pour la des vmc et christian
mauduit pour la ccm h et on a retrouvé
tous vos sites internet ont pour avoir
plus d'informations sur hbo aux
associations dans l'actualité également
les derniers chiffres de la délinquance
en ile-de-france révélés par le
ministère de l'intérieur bilan
globalement bon pour les homicides et
les vols et les braquages pardon qui
sont en baisse très mauvais en revanche
pour les agressions sexuelles qui ont
augmenté de 25% en un an à paris et dans
les hauts-de-seine et dans les yvelines
ce sont surtout les vols par fausse
qualité qui sont en hausse avec les
personnes âgées comme principale cible
suite de notre dossier à présent sur les
compétences du département des yvelines
l'une d'elles c'est la pmi la protection
maternelle et infantile à côté et des
centres la collectivité a également
mises en place depuis deux ans un bus
dédiés pour des consultations mobiles le
service réalise plus de 1500
consultations par an le sujet de mélanie
poquet il prend place près de la mairie
de ben deux mercredis par mois
le bus de la pmi le service de
protection maternelle et infantile une
compétence du département
il est équipé de deux cabinets destiné
aux parents et aux enfants de 0 à 6 ans
comme yacine 18 mois j'ai pris le choix
d'aller dans un centre permis par
rapport aussi autant qu'ils prennent
avec l'enfant parce que quand on va chez
un pédiatre on sait très bien que c'est
un rendez vous
un quart d'heure une demi-heure il faut
aller assez vite vite
ce bus reçoit en moyenne 17 fallu par
jour des consultations gratuites
assurées par un médecin généraliste et
une infirmière puéricultrice leur
développement psychomoteur leur
croissance
les vaccins si nécessaire dans l'examen
clinique et vaccins si nécessaire les
conscriptions également s'il ya besoin
notamment une vitamine et puis dépôt des
petites les petits tracas quotidiens
nous avons également un rôle sur
l'accompagnement parental dans le
développement de l'enfant les questions
sur l'alimentation sur le sommeil sur
qu'est ce que l'enfant fait au quotidien
si jouer ses occupations
le bus a été lancé il y a deux ans il
fait partie du grand plan de
restructuration lancé en 2015 par le
département l'avantagent de du bus c'est
que c'est très souple donc corps était
souple et on peut très bien se dire là
il ya un besoin plus important parce
qu'il ya plus de deux moments et plus de
naissances et on peut très bien créer
une halte
selon les selon les besoins pendant six
mois un an deux ans on ne fait pas de
purs hâtif c'est elle en fait on est on
est sur le conseil reçoit prévention
mais on ne fait pas de curative
c'est-à-dire un enfant malade on va pas
venir à mes amis pour une prescription
pour ce genre de chose qui aujourd'hui
24 centres de pmi sont implantés dans
les yvelines comme celui de guyancourt
déménager dans des locaux plus grands et
inauguré en novembre 2018 lorsque ces
centres qui étaient parfois ouverts
qu'une demi journée ou demi journée par
semaine puis s'être ouvert du lundi
matin au vendredi soir
de façon visible pour que les mamans qui
on n'avait besoin puissent accéder
facilement
dix communes se sont portées candidates
pour accueillir le bus depuis le 4 mars
une onzième les a rejoint
magny les hameaux est une nouvelle étape
mensuel les yvelines voit naître chaque
année vingt mille nourrisson mélanie
poquet que l'on retrouve en plateau
bonsoir ça tout autre sujet le retour de
votre coup de coeur culture une histoire
dont vous allez nous parler et mireille
la planche à 16 ans depuis trois ans sur
facebook elle est élue boudin dehors de
son lycée titre insultant qu'elle a
choisi de porter mais un jour elle est
seulement boudin de bronze le point de
départ d'une pièce les petites reines
présenté au prisme d'elancourt 1re au
départ c'est même un ouvrage de
clémentine beauvais qui est sorti en
2015 prix lire du meilleur roman
jeunesse de cette même année les prix
nouvelle revue pédagogique et le prix
1000 pages alors on y suit donc mireille
mais aussi hakima et astrid les deux
jeunes filles qui la devance dans ce
concours du boudin de l'année une
rencontre qui mène à un projet inédit
est présente le 14 juillet l'agad la
garden party de l'elysée
regardez un extrait de la bande annonce
et parents sont d'accord pour te laisser
comme ça à 12 ans sur les routes de
france traversée du port l élite à mes
parents sont des six poules atrides
[Musique]
c'est quand même pas vaillant de signer
à faire waouh sais pas ce qui s'est
passé mais d'un coup tout mon talent et
une maturité surprenante votre âge
pourquoi et c'est une pièce qui parle
d'un sujet qui fait souvent l'actualité
depuis ces dernières années c'est le
harcèlement sur internet
et oui du postulat de départ à un
concours méchant un titre des gradins
des boudins d'or d'argent et de bronze
les trois filles en font une force la
metteur en scène juliette henman
s'inspire du film little miss sunshine
et choisit aussi de parler de
l'exclusion de quoi et on exclut
pourquoi et surtout par qui un sujet
lourd dans une pièce touchante
un spectacle qui peut parler à tout le
monde pour sensibiliser merci mélanie
les téléspectateurs qui vous retrouve
tout à l'heure dans votre émission 7,8
culture et au chapitre culturel
justement coignières organise sa
première fête de la musique le 21 juin
la date est encore loin mais la
municipalité lance un appel aux artistes
pour sa programmation de cette première
acoustique les musiciens et chanteurs
aguerris mais aussi les amateurs de tous
styles sont invités à candidater d'ici
le 29 mars les dossiers d'inscription
sont à retirer en mairie ou à
télécharger sur le site internet de la
commune
[Musique]
elle le rendez-vous est habituel en ces
vacances d'hiver le cirque nicolas
zavatta production douchet s'installe à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines des représentations programmées
jusqu'à à dimanche avec une promesse
cette année un voyage en orient pour en
parler fredo douchet bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes l un des directeurs de ce
cirque
nicolas zavatta on va présenter bien sûr
le spectacle de cette année déjà pour
commencer votre le cirque fait partie de
la grande famille zavatta quelle est la
particularité de la production douchez
alors la production de chez fait du ciel
depuis huit générations avec avec mes
filles qui sont sur le spectacle et puis
on perpétue ce grand nom du cirque
zavatta et on est toujours content de
passer en région parisienne sur l'île de
france et tout ça car notre public ne
demande beaucoup surtout ici mènent à la
base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
on est toujours content de venir parce
que déjà sur notre site internet on est
déjà réclamé depuis au moins deux mois
que les gens viennent nous fait une
vraie tradition familiale qui se
transmet de génération en génération mon
père mon grand père mon arrière grand
père faisait déjà du cirque est
d'ailleurs sur sur notre propre cirque à
nous on est on est de deux garçons à
façonner de russie est mon frère qui a
été le plus jeune dompteur d'europe et
d'ailleurs il est sûr matin en train de
s'occuper de ces animaux et moi je suis
venu parler un peu notre circuit sur le
plateau une telle douche et dont on
avait consacré un portrait l'an passé d
une spécialité sur les fauves d'ailleurs
sur sur ce cirque oui en a on a tout
enfin c'est un c'est un magnifique
numéro on l'appelle le numéro arc en
ciel parce qu'il ya toutes les couleurs
de fauves qu'il existe une jeune blanche
tigres blancs tigre et habille les
lionnes du kenya donc c'est vraiment
c'est sympa quoi je l'enlève de ce
portrait de nickel douchez on voit les
images à l'écran oui pardon vous vouliez
ajouté peut-être je voulais dire que ben
voilà justement il passe à la télé il ya
deux golden tabbee ce magnifique tic qui
est très rare qu'il descendant du tigre
blanc qui fait presque 300 kg et qui a
lui mis à l'honneur oui c'est une vraie
passion vous le disais c'est un vrai
plaisir de revenir chaque année de
présenter un nouveau spectacle
c'est ça cette année ci fait le thème de
l'orient donc c est à dire des musiques
orientales de ça c'est vraiment sympa
c'est féerique tout le long du spectacle
on reste dans le thème et c'est sympa
qui en plus dans le désert de lorient on
a retrouvé la langue du génie et aladin
est franchement cette année spectacle
est sympa et ça donne envie
même nous tous les jours de remettre
deux sont atteints en scène parce que le
thème est vraiment sympa et d'ailleurs
chaque jour derrière ces représentations
il ya bien sûr la troupe de votre cirque
présentés nous cette troupe de qui ce
compostelle c'était alors cette année on
encore une troupe qui vient du brésil
les souza qu'on met à l'honneur car
cette année justement c'est c'est la
fête des 160 ans du trapèze volant et
donc on a mis à l'honneur les souza ou
sur une troupe de sept personnes à nous
rejoindre sur la tournée et ils nous
font un magnifique numéro de trapèze
volant
il nous faut aussi un magnifique numéro
de magie et il ya plein d'autres numéros
qui nous font parvenir des migrants
avant sensations et d'ailleurs comment
ça se déroule une année pour le cirque
nicolas zavatta ya d'abord une phase d
imagine de préparation après tout une
tournée il qui se déroule c'est ça alors
déjà on trouve vingtaine est un thème
accrocheur pour que cette année sur le
rien c'est vraiment sympa parce que
justement ça ça concorde avec avec toute
la ménagerie du cirque
car on a des chameaux on a déjà tout dit
début des costes et c'est sympa de
d'emmener des musiques orientales
derrière après on trouve une équipe qui
vient rejoindre la grande famille du
cirque sur une année parce que on au
cirque zavatta et dans tous les cirques
on appelle ça la grande famille du
cirque
il ya des familles qui viennent de toute
l'europe nous rejoindre pour une année
et ça fait la grande troupe de l'année
et cette année on est en une trentaine
de personnes à faire le spectacle
que ce soit de vendre devant au
spectacle dans la piste ou dans l'est
dans les coulisses et d'ailleurs on a
aussi encore un grand cru qui nous vient
encore du portugal
car pour moi même si au trapèze c'est
les brésiliens les meilleurs mais les
clowns pour moi c'est les portugais
cette année j'ai encore voulu avoir un
grand plus de portugais humberto muñoz
et d'ailleurs vous l'allaitez alors
cette année l'hôtel c'est le voyage en
orient le thème chaque année comment ils
se choisissent l'idée c'est de voyager
parce que c'est des thèmes souvent sur
qui invite au voyage entre c'est ça
alors c'est c'est toujours pour nous
c'est toujours assez durs à trouver
quelque chose qui accroche déjà qui
reste dans du rythme puisque le cirque
on doit on doit être dans le rythme on
amène les gens à faire un voyage comme
vous venez de lire mais on doit pas
avoir de temps mort et et puis après
faut associer les numéros qui correspond
avec ce thème
donc cette année la magie ça va être le
thème comme je vous disais toute la
ménagerie concorde avec avec le thème
mais ça nous vient comme ça on se décide
on est plusieurs
avec nos enfants et où on discute
ensemble et puis dès qu'il ya un dunk
accroche et puis qu'on pense que ça peut
aller pour la tournée est bon on se
lance dedans puis on voit si s'il ya une
équipe qui veut nous suivre sur cette
tournée vous en prie l'extérieur
quelques jours deux numéros on retrouve
alors sans tout dirigeant du goût des
voyages ce qu'il faut venir voir le
spectacle mais comme la nature on a 1
après 40 animaux donc spectacle efforts
sur les animaux la cavalerie l'effort
qu'on en parlait tout à l'heure mais
appréciée des numéros à grands auteurs
comme du cirque aérien un magnifique
numéro de trapèze volant
la magie il ya de l'équilibré il ya
aussi des sangles aérien il ya vraiment
pas mal de numéro et c'est féerique tout
le long parce qu'on reste vraiment dans
le thème tout le long du spectacle sur
al adha il est génie de la lampe
d'ailleurs à la fin du spectacle vous
retrouverez le génie qui sort de sa
langue et quels sont les jours de
représentations les horreurs alors là il
ya des spectacles tous les jours de la
semaine à 16 heures jusque samedi sauf
le dimanche qui à 15 heures donc tous
les jours 16 heures dimanche 15h la
tournée qui va se poursuivre aussi après
après le nul de loisirs sur elle re
d'accord mais la largeur à deux semaines
sur evreux pareil il y aura des
spectacles pratiquement tous les jours
dans une région voisine de l'île de
france
on trouve bien sûr toutes les
informations sur la page facebook du
cirque nicolas savate à douchez merci
fred oddou je suis à vous de nous avoir
invité et je rappelle que vous êtes l'un
des directeurs de ce circuit est
installée jusqu'à dimanche habile de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal un
cimetière qui prend des allures de
plateau de tournage à la verrière le
réalisateur tony chasselas tourne
actuellement une websérie sur de la
science-fiction michael et demi d'euros
et aurélie rond ont pu suivre les
premières prises un lieu plutôt insolite
pour un tournage dans les allées de ce
cimetière de la verrière on tourne le
premier épisode une web série intitulée
r&r rêve et réalité aux commandes tony
chasselas un réalisateur verrier roi de
35 ans on a lu cas c'est un
un journaliste local qui vient de perdre
son grand père et la perte de son
grand-père et touche énormément
ce qui se passe c'est que
il commence à faire des rêves et les
rêves il se demande si ses rêves sont
réelles en fait ne souhaitant pas
dévoiler l'intrigué le réalisateur n'en
dira pas plus sur le scénario de cette
web série qui comptera huit épisodes de
12 minutes
j'ai lu le scénario et j'ai tout de
suite fait l'histoire du coup je me suis
dit ok c'est parti on y va c'est un
match couperet voilà il ya beaucoup de
films qui se sont inspirés de tous et
voilà différentes en différentes
dimensions et tout ça ça me plaît c'est
de la sf mais s'est fait de manière
assez subtil et ça c'est bien écrit en
même temps du coup c'est pour ça que ça
me plaisait de de faire partie de ce
projet là ce n'est pas le premier projet
cinématographique pour tony chasse la
télé 60,18 l'avait suivie en novembre
2010 est sur le tournage de l'un de ses
courts métrages certes rue m
meurtres en verlan pour cette web série
le réalisateur a fait uniquement
travailler son imagination
les personnages y sont totalement fictif
je me suis même pas inspiré de quelqu'un
qui existait ou quoi c'est vraiment tout
ce que j'ai dans la tête c'est un
mélange de tout ce que j'ai que
que je mets à sur papier comme ça une
partie de la série sera également tourné
à coignières elle sera ensuite diffusée
sur les plates formes de streaming
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]